Before we end this lesson, I want to draw several connections.
The first has to do with memory. We have often said that memory is an integral
part of the cognitive systems architecture. One can imagine that A and
B are stood in a memory. Then C and 1, and C and 2, and C and 3, and so
on, are probes into the memory. And the question would then become,
which one of these probes is most similar to what's stored in memory?
We may decide on that answer based on some similarity metric.
In fact we'll revisit this exactly the same issue when we talk about case-based
reasoning later on in this class. Another connection we can draw here has to do
with reasoning. When we are talking about the transformation from A to B and
then the transformation to from C to 1 of these choices, one question that arose
was should we make the connection between the outer circle here and B?
Or the inner circle and A and B. This is a correspondence problem.
The correspondence problem is: given two situations, what object in one
situation corresponds to what object in another situation? We will come
across this problem again when we discuss analogical reason a little bit later.
The third connection has to do with cognition, of knowledge based AI as a whole.
Notice that instead of just talking about properties of objects,
like this is a circle and the size of the circle,
our emphasis here has been on the relationships between the objects.
The fact that this is inside the outer circle, or the fact that the outer circle
remains the same here, the inner circle disappears. In knowledge-based AI and
in cognition in general, the focus is always on relationships,
not just on objects and the features of those objects.